good morning everybody Welcome to Edna
this is our last executive session for
house
bills so all committee reports are due
today
and uh for information purposes I am not
scheduling any committee activity next
week so for whatever for so what
whatever re other activities you may
want to take care of uh we we I do plan
to schedule two days of hearings on the
4th and the 10th maybe it's the third
and the 10th the Wednesdays for and that
have yes excuse me representative Brown
for planning purposes no committee
meetings next week two hear two days of
hearings on the Senate bills we already
have on the 3D and the 10th those will
be full days but it'll get rid of all
the Senate bills we have
already and uh
and then we'll we'll go on from there it
looks like most of the Senate bills are
much easier than the house bills thank
goodness oh and for planning purposes if
anybody has something they want to bring
in as an a uh non- gerain Amendment we
have a Senate bill that is identical to
the social worker compact we have
already dealt with and I'd love to stick
an on Germaine Amendment on that one so
know well it is by definition identical
to the house
paper that's why I said that's it will
be much less controversial than any
other bill that we would want to gut and
replace so let me know all right we are
starting in our executive session
introduce representative Schulz and and
Howard and representative Platt who are
today and we're going to go heaviest
Amendment first so House Bill
1095 representative groda thank you I
move Amendment 20
24-21
12h as an amendment to House Bill 10 95
and I'll
second represent do you wish to speak to
your motion yes so um last year when we
passed house bills uh 655 and other um
bills that that concerned the
administration of
oplc um we
left existing statute regarding fees and
um
uh sorry
investigations licensing under the
board's
responsibility so this amendment moves
for all the boards that responsibility
from the board to the office so and so
right now this amendment as it stands
would correct all the conflicts between
oplc and the boards on not only uh
licensing setting fees for licens is an
application recordkeeping and
investigations it leaves with the with
the board the credentialing the um
adjudication of
complaints and um the the the components
of Licensing that the that really lie
with the board as far as its specialty
field okay and I'd like to add
administratively that this completely
replaces the contents of the bill the
proper pronunciation of conquered and
New Hampshire which we didn't see much
support from the committee or the public
at the hearing so if anyone objects to
that speak up N I won't object but I
just was hoping to find out the proper
pronunciation for no hamsha and
coner exactly actually there is an there
is an r and
conquer
representative schz as a conquered rep
conquered ah thank you that's a good way
to put it
anyway um so and this this is cleanup of
conflicting statutes this is a large
part of what we pulled out of House Bill
2 last year because we didn't have time
to work on it representative grota has
done a tremendous amount of
work this is down to 90 96 pages she's
taken about 30 pages out of it and it
it's
all it is
overwhelmingly technical Corrections
with no policy changes is that cor
that's yeah so that's what it is and I
might add representative um chair
McGuire that the the um boards that are
in 1271 one which is um the the board
the bill that these those boards were
taken out of this amendment so there'd
be no
conflict yeah we only want to deal with
each board once representative like meny
the second the motion on the amendment
what second oh you did yeah that's why I
was speaking pardon me represent man py
uh thank you madam chair so the question
you partially answered my question that
was coming with the are these amendments
or changes both for Advisory Board as
well as uh for um statute uh rul making
board right no any board that was
changed to an Advisory Board is in
1271 uh this is only and has been
removed from this amendment thank
you anyone else have a representative
goalie thank you madam chair and just
one quick question I know we discussed
when we were going through this
amendment about numerous
places that site office of professional
licensure versus just office and I see a
lot of the oplc still in here as versus
just office and I thought to be
consistent we were looking at cleaning
that up and I just want to
representative yes I spoke with OS about
that and they specifically called me and
they said said that they would like it
to be office of license of they would
like it to be license of uh office of
Licensing
certification because in um in
legislation where they talk about
departments they say the department of
and they specify so you'll see that the
beginning they they say office of
professional license certification and
then if the amendment I mean if the
paragraph is long enough they'll use
paragraph yeah I'm not I mean I'm not
going to vote against this because of
that but I see a lot of places where
they're still very inconsistent and I'm
not sure you know it is as
representative groa said that if it
deals with a section with multiple
references the first reference is
spelled out in detail and then the
subsequent references just say
office
you could for example I just opened to
page 58 and about
Architects paragraph one has the office
of professional license certification
and then down you know five page five
lines down it just says office and I'll
just site where I'm making my question
eight they start off with the office of
professional lure in Roman number one
and then you get down two when they're
still using the office of professional
lur so it's inconsistent you're so
correct and that was asked to them to
make it consistent and they still cannot
correct it appropriately and that's just
a point I want to make I'm not going to
vote against it on nitpicking on that
but they were asked to change and they
didn't do it all right thank you I
appreciate that representative
Brown uh thank you madam chair and does
that mean everywhere we had executive
director and all of our other bills that
is now no longer
um representative leus can should answer
that yeah if uh the final Amendment or
one before to
1271 after I spoke with representative
groa we went and changed it um to be
consistent with this and you'll see that
in the amendment probably the next most
weighty Amendment changing from
did
okay any uh any other questions comments
concerns representative
Simon thank you madam chair being late
to the party frequently on this
particular point I just kind of want to
jump out front and thank representative
groa for all of the hard work that she
did on this amendment I know she did it
for all the personal Glory that
typically comes from projects like this
uh but it was a tremendous amount of
tedious work and we're all very grateful
thank
you
okay all right anyone else
okay then the motion is to accept
Amendment 1212 to House Bill 1095 and
the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
leakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
Dolan yes representative PL yes yes
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes repres
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Howard yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
man py yes and the chair yes 208 Z all
right representative
Brer I move OT a to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 1095 second second by
representative Schmid all
right do you wish to speak to your
motion no I do not representative
Schmidt no okay does anyone have any
comments questions
concerns representative manuti a quick
comment even though the oplc is spelled
out and but the consistency of office
referring to oplc is a big improvement
from what it was before thank you yes
it's not perfect but it's better than it
was so so we
will we just don't want to deal with it
and we don't we don't have time to deal
with it anymore or get another iteration
of of
amendment all right anyone
else well we should just follow it to
make sure that the enrolled
bills perfects it because everything
You' said is exactly accurate uh and and
I agree with representative goalie too
that it should be consider IST the way
we want it okay we will uh see what we
can
do all right anyone else represented
leus yeah and just uh the Senate will
have their shot at it so if there's
stuff like that to clean up they could
take care of it if people want to bring
that to them yes we will certainly
expect them to
else okay seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1095 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative santon staso
yes representative Dolan yes
representative PL yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Howard yes representative
G yes representative Smith yes
representative Manti yes and the chair
yes 20 a0 n all right the motion passes
consent all right seeing none we'll put
this on
consent all right with the next heaviest
Amendment House Bill 127 representative
leus yes I'd like to adopt Amendment
H all right moved by representative lais
second by representative gold
representative laus okay so this um does
a number of
things um I'll deal with kind of the it
does some of the cleanup that was uh
taken care of in the amendment we just
voted for because the sections for these
boards was removed from there so that
should be similar but the substantive it
does uh the substantive thing is it
changes a number of boards from um
regulatory boards to advisory boards and
the the difference is that um the
regulatory board has the authority they
handle the ru making and while the
administrative stuff is handled by
oplc um the administrative board makes
the decisions any decisions necessary on
licenses and um they don't do the
investigation on complaints but they do
the adjudication on it an Advisory
Board um The Authority for doing the
rules and all that is with the office uh
the office is required to consult with
the board on all of
that
um but um you know once they once the
rules are in place then the uh
bureaucracy the gears turned there
following the rules and Grant licenses
or not you know as as appropriate
and they uh they handle the uh the
hearings and dealing with
complaints um there's a one of the
biggest arguments for having an Advisory
Board is in situations where you have
relatively few lies and the ones that
affected here are you know on the lower
end as far as the number of lenes
there's a problem when you have um a
small group you've got the market
participants um making decisions on who
can get licensed and what sanctions
exist if somebody is alleged to you know
commit some offense and there are um
antitrust problems with that I mean the
the most extreme example that's in this
bill are the midwives there are uh 33
currently licensed midwives in the State
uh with three being on the board You'
got almost 10% of all licensed midwives
serving on the board and they know all
know each other and so you know even if
everybody is acting in a completely
ethical manner there can be the
appearance of a conflict of interest
because they're making um you know
decisions on people who are arguably
potentially competitors and we heard
that there was a um a lawsuit in uh it
was North Carolina I believe where um
the state was sued over this sort of
thing and U the State lost and actually
the board and the members on the board
were actually held personally
financially liable for damages for doing
this and so there are reasons to make it
clear that things are being handled in a
a fair Manner and to remove some
liability from the state and actually
from the members on the
boards um and I can go and what the the
bill is drafted had uh there were some I
think cursory decisions on the
membership of the boards the boards were
generally reduced in size somewhat I
think mostly down to three and the
subcommittee I like to thank everybody
on it did an awful lot of work uh
especially looking at that and we made
quite a few changes in the amendment to
membership of the uh the boards and the
Midwife example um we changed the
membership basically to what what the
midwives wanted which was um you know
several three midwives and um one OB
doctor and one
pediatrician um and various changes like
that to to others and the membership of
the other boards which is which is
actually where we spent a lot of the
time on it to try
and come up with membership on the board
that that have we thought had the
expertise and represented the the groups
that were interested and um you know
went along with the feedback we heard
from people that provided
input
okay representative G and do you wish to
speak to your
second um no I think Tony said it all
thank you madam chair okay
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair well as we
all know or some of the others may not
know but we're on the record here and I
think it's I agree with everything that
representative leus just said uh and
some of these small boards uh they just
don't have the Manpower in addition to
the liability aspects that you reference
representative uh they just don't have
the Manpower and and a number of these
small boards they're only meeting once a
quarter uh and that that's just not
often enough to be on top of the the the
little nitpicking details that make the
difference whether you got a bearing
that's running smoothly or whether you
got a bearing that's got sand in it um
and and and so forth and it's it's very
important I can't emphasize too much
that we are not taking the authority
away from these smaller professions or
any professions in terms of scope of
practice and the the operation of the
profession itself except ad
administratively uh and that's what the
the
these none of the boards can be can be
absolutely assured that they are
completely on top of all the 91a aspects
and that that that type of thing that
are important for making sure you don't
step all over those statutes um and and
but we're not taking them away so
they're going to be standing out on the
street so to speak looking into the
window while the oplc runs Ru shod over
their profession that was never Our
intention I know that when the midwives
were before us a couple of years ago
those of us who were here remember they
were very afraid that we were going to
take away their profession and and let
the OBGYNs for example have the have the
the majority on the board so all those
kinds of things are not what we intended
we said it at the time but
so those aspects are very important and
that's why this executive session where
they we're saying we're we're not taking
away your profession we're only taking
away the nitty-gritty of of relicensing
and so forth so thank you very much for
the opportunity to address this okay
represent man py and then leus thank you
madam chair having served on this uh
subcommittee we spent hours and hours on
it which was great great learning
experience but I came out with the
thought that there were nine boards that
were listed to say going from regulatory
board to um Advisory Board and um my
understanding was that the regulatory
board set the scope and um you know and
The Advisory Board was recommending to
OPC the shift of the
professional uh um decision making moved
from the board to OPC and there were um
few boards that uh people who are very
well respected in uh their field uh were
very against it and I understand where
the uh um opposition came from and I do
respect that these people have done a
lot of work work on the board and we
have to listen to it so I will support
the amendment but I will not be able to
support
the bill as amended uh so there was I
still have concerns in terms of it so
thank you madam thank you representative
lus thank you um few points first I I
want to emphasize I agree with what
representative Schmidt said and want to
emphasize the fact that nothing in here
changes the scope of practice for any of
these um one of one thing I neglected to
mention is one of the things this does
is combine the exist the what were
existing advisory Boards of massage
therapists with the existing Advisory
Board of refle reflexology structural
integration and aging bodyw work therapy
that was done at the request of those
boards that wasn't controversial uh but
it is in here and on the the issue of
um the authority of the board um we did
add language requiring um oplc to
consult with the board on the rul making
which I understand doesn't require them
to go along with the board um but the uh
the members of the board also if they
don't like the rules that oplc comes up
with can be involved in the whole rul
making process everything from the uh
you know the public hearing written
input and I mean if they don't get
adjust they want their jail car so um
you know if if oplc does something that
is significantly counter to what the
boards want and the Bo and but and
they're being unreasonable then there's
plenty of places for members of the
board to or the board as a whole to
intervene and uh and I think that is I
mean I I you I think oplc is going to
want the expertise from the boards
anyway
but the fact that oplc isn't like the
dictator it can do whatever they want
with no remedy I think will be another
Force to push them to um you know to
work well with the boards and come up
with rules that I think will work for
both of them okay represent
goie thank you madam chair and first I
want to thank uh representative licas
and the subcommittee for the work they
did on this amendment um I'll support
the amendment but unfortunately I won't
support the bill um as
amended um I've been around here long
enough to know that when oplc was
created it was
to put together a place where
we we're going to take the office
functions that all the boards had
duplicative that they were doing with
printers staff answering phones whatever
it was when this was created with the
boards all had their own
separate board and separate
staff this was to create something that
would take those functions and
centralize
them and what I'm seeing here is the
office trying to continually grow away
from what it was originally intended for
when we put this
together and I'm not
sure back when when these changes were
made if I would have agreed with it if I
knew where we were going from
there because I'm watching
as the functions keep
growing out of this office
and I think we all when we did this were
adamant that the boards stayed separate
functions and had their own autonomy as
to what they were doing going
forward and starting to slowly make
these boards into advisory boards I I I
can't agree with so I I'll support the
amendment but not the bill as
amended representative leus yeah um I
understand that I just want to point out
that first of all the concept of
advisory boards isn't new with this bill
I don't know when it started but there
are a number of existing advisory boards
um
and and it's a you know having them have
autonomy in one sense makes sense but um
it also especially for a small number of
lenses presents real problems of
conflict of interest and that was uh
this was intended to
address and the other thing is that um
there are actually quite a few states
where they don't even have advisory
boards the whole licensing schemes in
the bureaucracy and the rul making
process um and so New Hampshire
actually more towards regulatory boards
and even advisory boards in quite a
number of other states it's kind of a
compromise and especially again for the
um
smaller um professions I mean we're not
looking at doing this for the Board of
Medicine or nursing or anything like
that because for one thing the potential
for conflict is dramatically less there
just because the large number of lenses
so that that was what was behind this
it thank you madam chair um
representative lake has made reference
to ways that board members can make
objections that they have known I assume
part of what he's referring to is the
oplc oversight committee that this this
committee was instrumental in creating
however we heard from some of the boards
who were involved in this bill that
until they got involved in this bill
they were unaware that that venue
existed and I'm not sure if how many of
the other boards are aware that they
have that
opportunity um one other thing and I
apologize for this because uh I was not
able to make many of your subcommittee
meetings and I realized that this was in
the bill itself but in the amendment on
page five down lines 23 through
27 I'm I'm just curious if your
subcommittee investigated how it's
possible for someone to do acupuncture
by tele medicine that just kind of blew
my
mind I believe that's more into the the
tone of dietary nutritional and herbal
therapies and lifestyle counseling than
actual acupuncture
just those just those items well that's
that's part of the scope of practice
okay I mean yeah I mean doctors can do
tele medicine but I think nobody
believes they're going to do surgery
that way at least at this
point robot surger consultation but
acupuncture to me is much more physical
yeah I think it it largely is but there
are other aspects as the chair uh
mentioned if I could uh there those are
those items are specifically mentioned
in the scope of practice on that page so
yeah representative laus yeah well when
I made my comments actually I wasn't
thinking of the um the op oplc oversight
committee although that is definitely
another venue what I was thinking of was
the um you 541 541a process of uh public
comment public hearing and then jel car
and um I don't think the board would
want to be I mean I don't you never know
who's going to be running the board in
the future I understand that but I don't
think any Board office I'm sorry office
of oplc is going to want to be in the
position of having a strong unified
opposition from a board on the rules
they're creating related to that
profession unless they've got an awfully
good argument for it um and so I think
and I understand the
concern of you know feeling that you're
ging up control and that you have
somebody up there that'll do whatever
they want but I don't think that's
actually a realistic
concern because um you know oplc is
going to be constrained on what they can
do and what they can get adopted that
was that was what I was thinking of
okay representative Schmid
Gro thank you madam chair so um I I I've
been on this board on this committee for
18 years okay I I was here before o PLC
was here um I wasn't here before Noah
was here but it sometimes it seems that
way but the bottom line is that I share
the concern that representative goalie
addressed that we we on were
already we were apprehensive about the
idea that the oplc was kind of being
given more and more and more Authority
and especially the executive director
when everybody was saying well the
executive director may be very
knowledgeable about this profession or
that profession but certainly not about
about all professions so how is he or
she going to be able to write the rules
and so forth and so on so uh and we
didn't know how that was going to work
out but I I think doing this at this
time is the right thing to do because uh
some of us who've been here for a long
time and and had these concerns and see
this very fine product uh and an
understanding of where we're trying to
go um and maybe we're going to be around
for a little bit longer I hope so anyway
and the thing is it's time to do it now
while we have the people here that have
a b the past experience and are going to
be here to nurse made this operation a
little bit longer about how it will work
out and and I think we have to do it
because uh otherwise we're taking the
risk that new people will come in won't
know anything about this uh won't have
our past experience and the the and
won't have the the sense of doing this
thing right and
having a this is a compromise and more
than a compromise it is a marriage of um
of two concepts uh that I think can and
will work if we if we are here to guide
it and and keep an eye on it as it as it
goes through the first um months or
years of doing this so let's do it now
and um and if there are problems let's
we will we'll be here to fix it uh for a
couple of more years thank you
represent thank you I wish was I was as
optimistic as repes representative
Schmidt that we're going to be able to
guide anything after this um because I
can tell you that's not going to happen
um and I will vote for the amendment I
will not support the bill because there
is disagreement in two of the boards as
to whether or not they should be
advisory boards I've received phone
calls from acupuncturist who do not want
this to be an Advisory Board I think
some of us have also receive those calls
I don't want to force anything onto
anybody which is why we have an oplc
oversight committee and I think they
should be part of that and I recognize
the amount of work that this that this
represents it's not easy to do the
things that you have to do um and I also
find it ironic that oplc can take all
this on and there's no fiscal note but
we want music
therapy um license and they need a
person so I have there's a big
discrepancy there and lastly this bill
did not come from oplc or from the
boards it came from somewhere else and
I'm not particularly keen on having that
as the reason that we're going to do
something so that's that's where I'm
going so I support the amendment I will
not support the
bill represent leus thank you uh just on
the fiscal note part oplc is already
responsible
for um all the investigation the
administrative part preparing everything
for the board hearings and all of that
um the only additional thing they would
really have would be um working on the
rul making but they would have been
consult in with the even if it was a
regulatory board they'd have to work the
board with the board on the rul making
even if the board had the authority so I
think that you know the basic idea is it
would it's not going to take them any
significant amount may you know whether
it's May almost be less work if there's
fewer board meetings I don't know that
there will be um so there's that and um
as far as the acupuncturist go you know
we had a few people that were actually
nobody showed up for the subcommittee
meetings and opposition they were all
for it vast majority of the email I got
was actually in support there was some
opposed um you know I I don't know that
we require unanimity in the profession
before we do something like this because
again it's it's to make sure that the
license the the professions licens
appropriately and the board operates
well and they don't necessarily all
agree on how to go about that either
so representative goalie and then Brown
here I look back at the testimony when
The Honorable Ned Gordon came here and
testified in opposition to the guardian
at Liam he had some great
points as to why they shouldn't
be this is someone who's been around a
long time I have great respect
for and I just look
and I look at the changes representative
Schmidt I look and I say
if it ain't
broke try and fix it we tried that
numerous times as we all know with the
retirement system and look where it took
us it took a long time to get it back to
where it needed to
be so and looking at this I say if it
ain't broke don't try and fix it I'm not
gonna I I'll vote for the amendment but
not the
bill representative Brown
thank you madam chair um I appreciate
what representative goalie said because
some of us don't know the history in
here and sometimes that would be nice to
know maybe a little earlier than
today that's not you personally of
course
um in the subcommittee we did have quite
a bit of conversation as representative
Lea said about the potential liabilities
for the boards as they stand because of
that court case that happened elsewhere
in the country and I think that there
was I think there was pretty much
agreement that it wasn't a bad thing to
try to uh fix that so that the The
Volunteers in these boards wouldn't be
subject to that kind of H lawsuit and
that's part of why going to advisory
boards uh would eliminate
that the other piece was we re I think
we did a really good balance
on saying we have too many Market
participants on the board versus having
no expertise in the field on the board I
think we balance that pretty well um we
didn't stick with the uh uh the numbers
of three as it came down it was
represented when the build the bill was
presented I think we pushed them all up
to five as opposed to maybe seven or 11
because of Quorum issues and we did try
to keep it I think pretty fair on the
balance as I said between Market
participants and and those that may uh
that aren't in the market and to get a
balance on opinions in there so I think
we did well with that
I think I said that twice yes
representative
gold you madam chair um having been on
the committee I really appreciate the
comments made by representative goalie
and representative Schmidt in terms of
the history and I'm thankful for the
institutional knowledge they carry and
and share with us all I also um
experienced a great deal of listening
and negot
negotiating to meet the needs
of of of the situation I mean we have to
remember that this amendment started out
with a bill that was repealing
everything and we had to get through all
the how to repeal the repeals and for
this dyslexic mind that was an
incredible activity of keeping it all
straight but um at the end of the
day I just have to say that I agree that
ad advisory or
regulatory are words more than their
power and that uh I really appreciate
representative Schmidt's words and his
admonition excuse me that it's not the
intent of this committee or any of the
legislation we send forward to strip
power away from people who are doing
such an important task and I know
representative mangipudi has pointed out
uh in regards to this in the past that
these people on these boards are vol
teers and they're not paid to do so and
um but in terms of it's not broken why
fix it uh I was going through the the
audit of the legislative budget audit
something
something yes yesterday and um a lot of
recommendations in there of delays
things that are happening that are
making the licensing process not go as
smoothly as it can go and a lot of that
has to do with functions that oplc can
can do and does do and you know I just
keep coming back to that change is hard
for people and that the changes we've
put the boards through with creating the
office which my colleagues have all
shared about the incredible work and
thought that went into doing that it's a
lot for people to go through and you
know I think this committee's made a
commitment to not keep pushing these
changes but we did have this big Bill
asking us to do some pretty serious
changes and I think we've done our best
to temper that and to make it reasonable
for the boards and I will say that I did
have an opportunity to follow up with
the woman who did come to the
subcommittee from the Midwifery board
after that part of the exec session was
done and she felt much better about the
compromise process that we went through
with her and adding some of those seats
back in and making changes that um that
would work well for
them thank you everybody all right any
representative us just on the point of
um The Guardian mlam board uh you know
we we saw what the bill originally
proposed it's my understanding that was
actually created in consultation with
oplc but
um and you know that didn't look right
what was in there and um a lot of work
went into that and I know uh member of
the committee representative Gul who had
experience in that area provided a lot
of input on the changes we made to the
board membership to try and do the right
thing and I think we did so just on that
point anyone
else okay the motion yes represent
goalie thank you madam chair I hate to
drag the cell but just one last point is
and I was looking for it I can't find it
right offand that we were given
some information from oplc on boards and
and in their criteria as to what they
boards and looking at the number of
lenses and a number of those boards
there were a lot more boards that met
the criteria of having a small number of
lenses in them I just have to question
why if it's so
important to convert these boards to
advisory because we're worried about
legal actions that only a handful of
boards were chosen out of those numerous
boards that met the criteria of the
numbers that they had talked about
during the
hearing why it was stopped there and not
just include every single board that was
with so many members or below so many
members and make them all advisory at
the same time and it wasn't done so I'm
not sure where the motive is or what's
think that us being liable for lawsuits
because of having a few number of lenes
per
board
um it's feasible because there's a lot
more Boards out there and if this was
really the ISS isue they would have
brought all those boards forward Under
One Roof um represent go I think at
least some of the boards with smaller
memberships that were not converted to
advisory in this bill were combined with
other boards in another bill and we
rejected that uh the board of Podiatry
for example would have qualified for
this bill but it was intent the U the
first pass was to combine it with the
Board of Medicine and we rejected that
and so I would expect that a conversion
to an Advisory Board would be considered
year there may be others I'm I don't
know all of them off the top of my head
representative
schmit thank you madam chair well this
is a very thought thoughtful disc uh
discussion I really respect uh my
colleagues uh and and I think that it's
not a bad idea it's not one way or the
other in terms of whether the the
concept that we're trying here uh is the
right idea uh uh but I think it
certainly makes more sense to start with
a few uh where we where we realize that
we have problems of what's typically
referred to as Manpower although it's
it's not has anything do with men and
women um and I I I remember that we had
um quite a fight a couple of years ago
with regard to court
reporters um these are skilled
professionals and those of us who sit on
jail car or some other uh committees
know what it's like to have a St court
reporter
stenographer uh uh making notes making
the record and having a tape recorder
the the work product difference is quite
considerable in terms of quality
and a court record that's got that's
filled with
inaudibles uh uh in the in the record it
says inaudible what well what was the
word that couldn't be heard that's the
that's the only record that the court
has in terms of somebody's life their
profession whatever um but the bottom
line is there aren't very many court
reporters anymore because we took them
out of the
courts well we didn't do it but it was
done by the legisl nature um and by the
well I'm not sure about that as a matter
of fact maybe in the courts the courts
got rid of them to the to their own
Peril um so I I I think it that this
again is on the record and and we're
we're we're creating a background
against which we're doing this
legislation so I think that if we're not
doing all of them at the moment it's
probably not a bad idea let's try it out
and see how it works if it doesn't work
well then we can fix it won't be the
first time that we two steps forward one
step
backward when I was in the Marine Corps
walking the walking my post in the
middle of the night with nobody around
for Miles sometimes I would do two steps
forward one step backward anything to
keep just doing it for four more hours
so the thing is I I we're we're going to
I'm going to support this I'm I'm sure
I'm going to antagonize some of my
Democratic colleagues because they think
we're doing doing the wrong thing but
I'm willing to give it a try because I
don't think we can just go
forward without any
changes we don't have the Manpower in
many of these small boards and we got to
got to supplement that taking away all
the administrative stuff all the simple
stuff and letting them run their
profession let's do that thank you other
comments representative Brown uh thank
you madam chair uh following up on what
representative goalie said here uh I I
don't know the answer to this I'm going
to throw it out there for
discussion uh so there the conversation
was as I said some of these boards we
went to advisory so that maybe they
wouldn't be subject to uh
liability as has happened in the rest of
the country but why weren't why wasn't
that consideration taken for every board
or was I don't know if representative
leus can follow up on that or anyone
else just for discussion purposes
representative
leus I can't um answer for all the
boards I mean uh there was a one on the
pediatrist that the chair mentioned but
similarly for the land surveyors there
was an attempt to merge them with uh
Board of engineering which we thought
didn't make any sense but um I would
suggest uh in the future to have them be
in an Advisory Board would would
probably be appropriate and and I agree
with representative Schmidt I mean there
are some advantages not to try and do
too large a chunk at one time and then
and then you know see what happens thank
you I'd like to say that it's very
possible that these boards are the ones
that had trouble getting enough people
appointed to the board they had trouble
meeting because they couldn't get a
quorum and those were therefore selected
for the first round of uh
conversion to advisory because that that
was a major issue for a number of boards
representative
sh thank you madam chair I'm I'm
listening to all of these points and uh
reminded that regarding the guardian ad
Liam board which was left in this
amendment uh this full committee during
the hearing heard from a very esteemed
former member of both bodies of the
legislature who served on the guardian
at lien board that he felt that this was
absolutely the wrong thing to do uh with
that particular board um and I um I
think I agree with most of my colleagues
that um I will vote for the amendment
because of all the hard work that went
into it but I'm sad to see that in it
and therefore I will not support the
bill
finally pres goalie thank you madam
chair I just want to thank
representative Brown for the one of the
pieces of paper that we received uh to
look at and when I look at when we talk
about number of meetings or number of
lenses and I look at acupuncture has 190
lenses which I think is more than enough
to not say that there's a conflict six
times
light them they met three
times referee met 12 times this is all
during fiscal year 23 that we received
from
oplc um so I would say they are
meeting I would say
that there are a few here
that have more than enough lenses to say
there's not a
conflict um so once again for that
reason I mean
I'll support the amendment but not as
amended
okay all right on that note the motion
is to adopt Amendment 1248 to House Bill
1271 and the clerk can call the role
represent Simon yes representative lakis
yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
Dolan yes representative PL yes clerk
wrote yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative
Schultz yes representative Davis yes
representative Howard yes representative
G yes representative Smith yes
representative maner py yes chair Yesa
Z representative Simon thank you madam
chair before we go into the um vote I'd
like to request five minute caucus if I
case we know what we'll leave we'll be
glad to leave we'll find a home
somewhere okay well we could go into the
office
yeah fine we will resume at 11:30 and I
think the Democrats will CAU will stay
e
stories I could fish around for
[Laughter]
you I do um I'd like to move ought to
is there a second I'll second Madam
chair
okay you wish to speak to your motion um
I think we said most of what needs to be
said the only thing
I'll I'll say is that um you know I
don't see this as a power grab the the
right now um oplc we've gave them the
authority to do the investigation I mean
they don't have expertise in all of the
uh professions but they hire people or
consult with people to provide that um
and they'll be Consulting treating the
boards that way Consulting with them on
rule making and I think there's
mechanisms in place to make sure they
don't go run a muck and do something
bizarre as I mentioned and the other
thing is
that um they're kind of the what we
heard and other other things I've seen
the the way the courts are handling
antitrust has changed somewhat and I
think there really is you know part of
this is risk
mitigation partly to the state and
partly to the boards I mean the the one
down in the um Carolinas there was some
uh hundreds of thousands on judgment
against uh against the individual
members of the board and uh I don't want
to see that here and I think there's
something you know there's risk of that
and I think that risk has grown so
that's all I have to say representative
Simon uh nothing to add I think we've
discussed it at length Okay anyone else
have a comment
question all right in that case the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
and the can can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakas representative Bailey yes
representative San staso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
PL yes clerk votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative Brown yes
Representative groa no representative
Schmidt
no represent goalie no representative
Shu no representive Schultz no
representative Davis no representative
Howard no representative G no so that
another motion can be made
representative Smith no representative
10 all right is there anyone who wants
to go through the exercise of having an
itl motion that will result with a 1010
Vote or should we just re recommend no
recommendation could I recommend um
interim study I make a motion for
interim study second all right interim
study by representative gr seconded by
representative
gold any
discussion sure um I'd like I I do think
that we should look at this I think it's
an important
um
evaluation and I'd like this do an inim
study with the other Bill to to discuss
with the oplc oversight committee as to
what we can do Al together including the
boards and including the office of of a
liur and certification so I think it
should be a group effort and I'm hoping
that the committee will see this as a
good faith measure to get this done in a
more amicable way thank you
representative gold thank you madam
chair yes I um
I was very happy to hear the commitment
that this will be an interim study this
is not a a polite way to make this all
go away and that my colleagues are
committed to making it happen and and
working with those um those people who
are opposed to anything left in this
bill and and giving it the time it needs
so that we come out of this with a good
situation because we do support the work
that went into it
anyone else representative
Schmid thank you madam
chair well as I said
before I've been on this committee for
years okay I've been on the Jael car for
years I've seen committees that work
hard that care about one another as well
as about the work they're
doing uh and I'm I'm persuaded that
there there are aspects of of this
situation that we have not explored
enough and I don't want to dive off the
diving board and have this go to the
house where it'll just be a partisan
situation I have a lot of respect for
the conversation we've had where we have
really worked and it where we're not
bashing one another's politics or
whatever uh and and and I I I think
there's there's too much Merit to the
continued
cooperation uh to to turn it into a
straight um vote in the house and God
knows what will happen in the Senate and
so forth so I think interim study where
we can really get at this uh is the way
to go so I'm going to vote for in study
anyone else representative laus so I
appreciate the comments I don't see this
as a political issue I'm going to oppose
an N study and we'll see what happens um
um you know if it were to pass the house
and if there are things that need to
come out of it I mean you could make
that argument to the Senate they might
very well go along with it um but the
thing bottom line is I think it is the
right way to go and and that's my view
okay anyone else representative Brown uh
thank you madam chair for for my
edification when when does this start
and when does it end an interim study
interim study starts as soon as we deal
with everything else or sooner if we
like and it ends with a report in
November thank
you and it obviously pre means that this
bill is dead for the uh
session okay any other
comments
okay the motion is interim study by
representative broa and the can call the
role represent
time
no Representative lakas no
representative Bailey no representative
San staso no representative Dolan no
representative PL no CL no
representative Boyd no representative
Brown
yes representative groa
yes represent Schmidt yes represent
goalie yes represent Shu with the hope
that we can come together yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Howard yes representative gold gratitude
yes representative Smith yes represent
one
two why am I count
apologize represent leus do you wish to
write a Minority
Report um yes when's it due today today
uh how about after the end of of
today sooner if you can well I generally
don't do it on my phone my computer's at
home and I would do it when I got back
it's afternoon or evening well you're
welcome to use
mine
please
okay on House Bill 1688 which has the
right Madam chair yes um clarification
ation
1226 no no this is a revised Amendment
1254 which is hot off the press and it
should be making its way around oh okay
there may be two you may have to uh I
divided
it so this
amendment
does a couple of things first it takes
the definitions of AI and makes them
exactly the the same as in other bills
that we've got this year there's one in
criminal justice there's one in
judiciary and there's one in election
law so we have made sure that the
definition is the
same okay on under the
prohibitions it eliminates a couple of
the
prohibitions that were flagged uh one at
the hearing one at another meeting I was
at as might be problematic because we
don't have the time to really deal with
them um that's the prohibition on uh uh
counseling I think it
was cognitive
behavior changes and
um look at the original bill
on right right that that was considered
problematic by some people at the
hearing
and I didn't want to include
problematical issues the other was the
disparate impact
which uh several people at the meeting
where we talked about the definition
said that might be an
issue so we said fine we'll we'll just
identify prohibit
unlawful classifying persons to result
in unlawful
discrimination real uh biometric
identification systems for
surveillance um facial recognition voice
recognition except with a
warrant and deep fakes for any deceptive
purpose which seems
fine um then it uh goes on to say that
the
agency use of AI must comply with with
this chapter and the doit code of
ethics that is available it's on their
website it's on the fact it's on the top
of their their website and it covers a
lot of uh points in more detail than
should be in
statute so
um that's now complying with that is a
requirement and then it requires doit to
one-time report on these
systems the
uh uh Professor Corman who worked with
us on this amendment put also added the
severability clause which I don't think
is necessary but it can't
hurt so and this is an amendment from
myself representative groto who worked
with the subcommittee on it and
representative Corman who is the author
of the bill it is also not opposed by
DOI
um it it simplifies the bill a little it
makes it the definitions
identical and puts the U ethics
requirements um into into
law representative
Bara thank you madam chair I have
nothing to add okay question represent
BL us yep I was just wondering if you
were someone could say a little more
about what the concerns around cognitive
behavioral manipulation was just uh
because it's used for counseling in some
cases the suicide
hotline okay they're trying to convince
people not to uh uh commit
suicide so rather than give them an
exception or try and figure out how to
phrase it that we just say that's that's
too complicated for today okay
so and I believe okay anyone else
questions comments
representative thank you madam chair so
uh this is you know coming up like
uh
um like
a ballistic missile fired from someplace
that's portending Doom but uh
uh I I'm pleased to see that uh sponsors
are um people I respect and bipartisan
and so forth because I certainly think
that this is an issue that is becoming
more and more uh um more scary uh and
threatening than uh than I I thought it
was at the very beginning um and and I
think it's it's it's it's going to
be very much worse very fast so I'm I'll
support
this represent R py thank you madam
chair um I think that this is a step in
the right direction whether we like it
or not it's here and it's going to be
part of our lives and to take a
proactive step in the right direction
and not be um
respon reactive and knee-jerk reaction
to say how we have to do it we have to
do something because it's here at our
doorstep and I think it is really um was
I had the opportunity to sit through the
subcommittee and
that problem solving came through and
this is really a good move and I commend
the subcommittee for coming together
with the very appropriate
Amendment thank you thank you anyone
yeah i' I'd like to add that this is
only a Prohibition on some aspects of AI
by the state it does not affect any
private entity it does not affect local
governments actually it's only state
agencies which we definitely have the
control okay anyone
else okay then the motion is to adopt
Amendment 1254 to House Bill 1688 and
the cirk can call the role represent
Simon yes yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Sasso yes represent Dolan yes PL yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative SCH
yes representative Davis yes
representative Howard yes representative
G yes representative Smith yes
representative man buy yes and the chair
yes 20a z
n okay and I move ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill
1688 I'll
second
okay and
you represent gr you have a um no I have
nothing to add either okay anyone
else questions
comments okay seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
1688 and the clerk can call the role
represent Simon yes representative lakas
yes representative Bailey yes
representative saso yes representative
Dolan yes representative PL yes cler vot
yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Howard yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
manuti yes and the chair yes 20 a0 n all
right motion passes 20 to Z any
objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
consent all right finally House Bill
1622 this is resumed from last executive
session where we passed an amendment and
then paused representative Simon you
have a motion yes thank you madam chair
I would like to move Amendment
second you wish should speak to your
motion uh yes thank you madam chair
after our discussion last time um I did
some work on this um taking some of the
language out of
1521 um placing it into amendment to uh
be added to
1622 um lines 4 through 12 deal with uh
much of the material that was in
paragraph
um making sure that public comment um is
posted when it's received
electronically um and then also uh as
resources would allow uh anything
submitted by regular mail would also be
scanned and added um to the web page for
electronic documents it does require
that each rule has its own specific page
uh where those comments would be would
be posted so that's the um so that the
public can find it easier that's the
gist of the first section there and then
13- 17 um this section here um it's
actually already in statute RSA 541
a12e um the concept is anyway we're just
kind
of um giving greater detail kind of
expanding on it a little bit um so it
presently reads a report of the public
comment shall uh received on the rule
shall be created the report shall
indicate how the comment was
incorporated into the final rule if the
comment was not incorporated into to the
final rule a substantive explanation of
the adopting Authority overrall relevant
arguments and considerations made in the
comment shall be included so just
basically saying if you didn't take the
rule uh you didn't take the comment into
the rule why didn't you take the comment
into the rule and having to give some
sort of uh substantive explanation for
that so that's the gist of the amendment
okay and Al this is the a large part of
what was in
1521 other than the problematic delays
and um time phasing that would would
have required the total rewrite of the
uh
uh of the of the entire rul making
process but these um and this expands on
the the how the public comments are
reported to we already require a report
that is was newly in newly effective
this past October so we haven't seen a
lot of them but this will expand how the
agency responds to comments and that was
a big part of the concerns that
generated
1521 representative leus um thank you
that's just to make sure I understand
what we're doing here um am I correct
that this amendment just adds to 1622
and does not change anything already
there that's the first part and second
is um forget exactly what we did in the
last exact session of the bill but um is
anything that we might have done there
included in what we're in the bill or no
this this bill adds the the new
paragraph Y and then it amends another
section of 541a that was not included in
1622 okay all right so it'll be the bill
as introduced plus the amendment plus
the amendment we did last time okay
that's what I trying to all right that's
what I was asking about we adopt this
amendment we will
our uh our researcher will have to make
sure we get a single amendment that
includes both of them okay thank you
okay representative Schmid thank you
madam chair uh
so just as a general comment I'm very
supportive because I think this is step
in the right direction uh but my
question is um line
16 the language um it becomes somewhat
opaque in terms of what is actually
intended by by the
phrase explanation of the adopting
Authority overrule relevant
arguments um because I'm not sure I
understand that um uh as a former German
Professor I look at and say directly
translated from the German I think uh
because it seems like a
long representative Simon do you wish to
explain the uh thank you madam chair uh
first I would say that's not how I wrote
it um and I get it at about 10:15 right
before the meeting started so I didn't
have time to R but I think I understand
what they're saying um they have to give
a substantive explanation the adopting
Authority would be the the group who's
writing got that that part was um so
they overrule to the relevant arguments
there should be another word in there
probably to the relevant arguments and
considerations made in the comment
section but I think we can probably get
that polished up after I I just we we
want to understand what we're saying
there because it certainly is not a
common
construction uh and uh so let yes if I'm
not misten could we say when we're
getting the SEC the final amendment that
instead of
overrule we should say decision to
overrule that's what was there before
they they changed the language to this I
think decision to overrule makes much
more
sense
representative Brown you have a comment
well actually I do understand it is
written there you go
so overrule relevant arguments is a
single noun right that's
an adopting the our Authority or
authority you could change
uh you almost killed him
Carol it's an effect they have on people
apparently well I have to admit that
isn't something that the naive reader
would immediately accept so uh I think
we
right that's that's something I can fix
after a vote on it though correct okay I
if it doesn't change the substance right
I think so since we're going to need
M yes representative PL I'm reading this
and if this if it struck out adopting
Authority overrule and just said
incorporate in the final rule of subst
explanation of the relevant arguments
and considerations made in the comment
shall be
included that makes makes sense because
of the my English at work and I didn't
take German I took
French of the relevant arguments and
considerations made in the yeah that
that
makes excellent I think we will uh
approval yes
our no I mean because that's what they
want they want the com the a substantive
explanation of the relevant arguments
and considerations
okay is that agreeable to you
representative Simon um I think that I
think that the
overrule part of it is important I'm not
sure if he said that that was in there
or not explanation of the of overruling
Rel of the authorities I don't know I
think the overrule was part of the point
if we leave that word out I think that
um because that's the that's the bigger
concern the bigger concern is when they
don't incorporate the comment why didn't
they incorporate the comment that would
be the overrule on it so all right
represent Madam chair I think it's clear
to begin with because if the if comment
was not
Incorporated that that just says it
right there if the comment was not
incorporated then a substance in the
final rule subst explanation relevant of
relevant arguments and considerations
made in the comment shall be included
because so the whole point the whole
point it wasn't adopted therefore right
yeah right and having seen some of these
um against the adoption well well I mean
the the in some cases they say you know
yes we agree with this comment we've
included it in the rule which is easy
but they need to put substantive
explanations of when they are
disagreeing represent gr maybe I've just
read too many amendments
but I don't think that this needs
clarification this makes this is very
clear to me it says that public comments
have to be created for the rule and if
the report doesn't incorporate the
comment they have to be able to explain
why and how they can how their consider
and how that that consideration was
incorporated in their decision so this
to me is is very clear I don't think we
need to change
anything all right
well as the as the grammar mavens are
all right
so do you want to try and tweak the
language or let's have a vote on but
show of hands those who are in favor of
the language as presented raise your
hand two four six seven eight 10 12 14
16 okay those who that's a majority so
we will let the uh the grammar
mavens argue about it be if it's go if
it's totally clear to at least two
random members of the committee who are
not
lawyers I think it makes sense
then I think I think it's good
enough all right Senate can always tweak
it if I want you all right so any uh any
other comments other than the uh the
grammar
all right seeing none the motion is to
adopt Amendment 1226 H to House Bill
1622 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
leakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative sanon staso yes
representative Dolan yes representative
PL yes clerk vote Yes representative
Boyd yes representative Brown yes
representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Howard yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
manager py yes and the chair yes 2 a0 N
okay the amendment passes I move ought
to pass with Amendment on House Bill
1622 second by representative
gold okay any any further comments
questions
concerns all right we did beat this up
fairly thoroughly last week
so
uh okay the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 1622 and the
clerk can call the role representative
Simon yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
sanon staso yes representative Dolan yes
representative PL yes clerk votes yes
represent representative boydd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Howard yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
Mana py yes and the chair yes
2a0 okay motion passes 20 to zero is
seeing none we'll put this on consent
okay so that is the last of our house
bills thank you all for
lasting and um committee reports are due
today as soon as possible that's one two
from representative groda two from rep
one from representative leus and two for
me okay they will be ready and no
for